rồi thì rồi thì mình cho cột qua hay đại hành trị rù cách mình đồng nhau
khách cách mình mừng nhau
và có ký thất nhìn mình dưới
thì game như ký thất cái này là tạm tạm
cái này là một trong ai tư sân mét
thì chêu cao để bằng sống người sân mét
và tổ ra kẹn xếp ở đây phải nó bằng sảo sống
Mời tông bộ bơm đứa bảo thùng
là 2 người li trên phúc
các bạn nhớ li của chúng ta để xin mẹ khối
tôn nhân kìm mình đôi sân mét
tại vì tất cả mọi thùng số người nâna sân mét
và tông nương sân mét ở cách mình của thùng nhợ
bình bị sân mét trên phúc, khi chêu cao mừng đo ra hành nằm sân mét bằng bằng nhau
như vậy các bạn thì vô gió cái câu ở đây tôn nếu tục nước tôn này là cách mình
ở cách mình